everyone uh my name has introducers
more people in the geography called me
which is my first alphabet if you want
to talk to me call me K it's easier that
way uh
so yeah
um today uh I'm going to talk to you
about
um
a journey right like and this is the
same Journey our Merchant stake with us
every single day and
I want to talk to you about how we use
different machine learning models along
that uh journey to make as much as life
just a little bit easier or
and before I do that a quick
introduction on Shopify
um how many of you heard of Shopify
before
okay great uh and for those of you who
haven't heard of us before uh Shopify
essentially uh is a platform which
provides all the required tools uh for
you to run a Commerce business or we
started way back in 2006 and
um we'll grow clearly those numbers show
you how much we've gone we Now operate
pretty much in every country in the
world uh most of you would have at some
point purchased something from a Shopify
Merchant whether that's in person or
online or you would have purchased
something from a Shopify version except
you probably didn't realize you were and
that's quite the same like we want to
put our Merchant front and center uh so
you can see some of those numbers out
there uh that gives you a sense of scale
in which we operate
so a little bit about me you already
know my name like I said call me K it's
easier or if you want to challenge them
uh for some reason people find that hard
but yeah I work as a staff data
scientist on a tech read over a Shopify
um I've I've had over 10 years of
experience in productionizing machine
learning models uh in different domains
or retail at Tech and Healthcare
specifically
form
think about these I have a very strong
belief in systems thinking or in fact a
lot of today's discussion is going to
touch upon that uh we're having said
that I'm also a firm believer in
going whatever it needs to be done to
solve the problem at hand as quickly as
possible because those two things aren't
necessarily always and conflict in fact
there always is a way which is both
quick and easy but also helps in
iterating towards building a robust
system in the long term and that's going
to be the theme of what I'm going to be
talking about a little bit here as well
and outside of work those are the things
that I'm super interested in and in that
order right uh so yeah that's a little
bit about me
um so here's the agenda I have for today
that
um so we're going to take a journey like
I said and uh we're going to take the
same Journey that every Shopify Merchant
is going to take when they join us and
along the way we're going to see how
Shopify is using these interconnected
machine learning models at every step of
the way to make our devotions life a
little bit easier and a little bit
smaller effect are so we'll start off by
talking about the different problems
that you and me will encounter if we
were to run an e-commerce business right
whether it's the Shopify or whether it's
somewhere else like these are common
problems across the board and we talk
about what those problems are and then
we pick up pick a few of these problems
right like when I wish I could talk
about every single problem and how
software is trying to investors we don't
have the time for that so I pick a few
of these
and we'll talk about how we're
specifically using machine learning to
tackle these problems and then finally I
touch upon a little bit on the
infrastructure side of yeah it's all
well and good to talk about hey these
are the fancy ml models we have but how
do you actually
go from an idea than a data scientist or
an ml engineer had in his head quickly
getting it prototyping it and getting
into production and doing it in a way
that allows us to quickly iterate and
scale right so we talk about the
infrastructure a little bit
um so with all of that said oh let's
start the journey together
so where do we start our journey oh
let's sort of the very very quickly
let's say all of us today have an idea
and say hey I know this great product
that I want to sell maybe I want to sell
it online maybe I want to sell it in a
retake location but what if you have an
idea of what we both said yeah let's go
create a Shopify scope let's start there
right so where do we go from there right
so the first thing you do is you join
Shopify we have different tiers of
service you create a free store
essentially it's a website you create
you create a storefront and so there
where do you go from there just having
the storefront doesn't give you sales
right there's a lot more that goes to
Farmers than just movement right
first thing we want to do is maybe we
want to do catalog management right um
especially in the world where I want to
sell across multiple channels right
maybe you want to send it on your store
you want to sell retail maybe you want
to sell it to Google Facebook Instagram
Tick Tock wherever right so we have all
of these different channels that you
want to sell on how do you do catalog
management
let's say you solved that problem
then we're like okay I have a fancy
website I manage my products I have a
catalog how do I actually get customers
right uh in fact this is one of the
biggest problems that any uh child
placed over any retail store with my
face right how do you find customers
let's say we did find customers then we
were kind of like manager and Retreat
right again like I said we're selling
across multiple channels how do you how
do you manage your inventory right uh
let's say you did that right then you
have to manage check out the different
payments different Payment Systems all
of them check out comes with its own set
of
challenge of structure you want to do
checkout right let's say you solve that
now you're there with Logistics and
shipping right again this is an easy
especially as a scale Logistics and
shipping becomes really really hard
right so how do you tackle that right uh
and maybe your business grows okay that
we want to have a bunch of automations
as we scale and protocol right and after
all of that I'm still like hey I have to
be with fraud and I have to deal with uh
fraud protection not just for me but for
my customers as well right uh just and
there's many many more right this this
list can go on and on right uh but
essentially we can start quickly
realizing how complex this journey can
get right running the Commerce business
isn't just a stop isn't just opening the
Shopify store and having a fancy website
it goes beyond that right there's a lot
of things that go into Congress so our
Channel 5 we believe in helping our
merchants and every step along this way
right and we have different teams that
focus on different aspects of this and
what we've come to do in the last few
years is we've realized that machine
learning can help us around all of these
and if ml has started to become more and
more embedded into every step around
this journey and today I'm going to talk
to you about some of those Journeys
right and how they're not operating in
isolation but they actually talk to so
if you have all of these machine
learning models that are interoperating
with each other and so that's going to
be what we're going to talk about right
um like I said when I wish I could talk
about all of those use cases right I'm
going to take on three specific topics
today right uh first we're going to
start with catalog management right
um and how we're using machine learning
to make this easier for our Merchants uh
to organize their store right uh
specifically I'll talk to you about how
we're using the national language
processing in computer vision to
automatically generate metadata around
our products so that this is used across
multiple things right like things like
search and Discovery taxation there's
many use cases for this right uh so once
we do that I'll then talk to you about
how this price then into alien link on
Merchants to do uh better online
advertising especially today in an
ever-changing model interest to
advertising it becomes very confusing
and hard for our religions and so
Shopify audiences this is a product we
just launched earlier this year and how
these two things tied together
finally there are talking about how we
evolved from just product Cate
application into more visual attribute
extractions
um and so these three things will then
tied together and then like I said at
the end of all of this I'm going to
knock you about the infrastructure and
the platform that we built that supports
all of there's a quick iteration
what you're going to see is how these ml
models are not just talking to each
other who they share common commonality
both at an infrastructure level and also
at the model level
um so let's start with product
characterization for those of you who
remember from my uh from my previous
slide dogs those are my two dogs that
are uh so let's say I want to sell that
doctor like we I've created my business
who's asking rent that I want to sell it
right
um I want to now manage my Capital right
the first thing you know if any of us
are shopped online we know that surge 25
search dog bed like this has to show up
and then I'm going to say hey I wanted
gray color and I want it
all these are essentially attributes
right how do we how do we get that right
so first of all like I need to know that
it's a doctor
if I know that the next thing I want to
know is it says
I need to know in shape I need to know
fill material onwards and onwards right
so obviously I can rely on the merchant
to manually enter it right but that's
both inefficient and creates friction
for the merchant right if there was a
way for us to automatically do this for
our Merchants probably a better solution
and so that's where a product
classification came in right so we
wanted to see if we can use all of the
data we have we've collected a lot of
data
um around products and their metadata
and we were like let's see if we can use
machine learning here uh to train a
model and make predictions to extract
this metadata
so before we could start doing it we
needed a control list of what categories
are right I just said dog bed is a
category but how do I know that right
maybe maybe bread is the category right
why not but right why not animal bed
right so we needed a control list of
categories and this is where the Google
product taxonomy came in
um like the name suggests uh Google came
up with us they maintain it uh and we
kind of just piggyback on top of that
here is a single branch of the Google
product taxonomy right so this taxonomy
isn't a flat structure it's hierarchical
in nature right so this is one single
branch of the taxonomy we start at level
zero or one uh with arts and
entertainment and you can see quickly
how how granular it gets by the time I
get to the the bottom most level it's
talking about clarinet care kits right
so we started an arts and entertainment
and gets to parent and Care kids and
this is one branch of uh hierarchical
taxonomy right uh
there are over 5500 different nodes in
the Stream which basically means there
are 5500 categories right and in this
example
um we can kind of see why we need it
right because we can do aggregations at
different level right maybe there is for
taxation I might need to know that it's
a clarinet care kit but for I don't know
financial reporting maybe I just need
arts and entertainment and that's enough
right so I can kind of aggregate at the
level that I need to be in for different
uh purposes so this kind this this tree
structure makes it very easy from a
consumer perspective but from an ml
perspective it introduces all sorts of
complications and challenges right like
because most of us are used to a flat
classification system which is easy but
this creates an additional layer of
complication right uh and so
is this a service that you purchase from
Google or is it it's um it's Google is
it's an open source taxonomy that you
can use uh in fact most
um it's an industry standard at this
point like Facebook uses it uh there's a
bunch of other uh
e-commerce companies that use the Google
products
so
before we get into the model itself a
quick note on the scale at which we
needed to operate uh
historically Shopify has had billions of
products that our Merchants have created
and sold right uh and we've collected
tens of billions of images across these
billions of products right uh and so
every time we train a new model one of
the requirements we had from our
internal consumers was that we need to
perform historical backfills for all the
products that we've ever sold right uh
you can question that requirement but
it's just internally we needed to do
that for different purposes right uh and
furthermore
forget the historical backfill for a
second even just going forward our
Merchants are creating tens of millions
of products on a daily basis
these are updates creates and we want to
kind of keep updating our predictions as
changes happen to our products so that
was something that we had to kind of
consider right
and after all of this uh there are
different kind of different Downstream
consumers right uh like some of the
examples you see up there right product
sync search
taxation admin analytics there's all
sorts of use cases for product
categorization
um and not all of these have the same
access patterns right some of them
require us to do real-time predictions
right uh as the merchants typing in or
changing things in the admin we want to
add real-time update our predictions
there are other applications where we're
kind of like hey I don't care about
those intermediate predictions but all I
care about is when the data hits the
production database I wanted it updated
as quickly as possible for I don't know
fraud use cases or something right so
there are different use cases that have
different access patterns and we needed
to support all of those different access
patterns as well uh
and so those are some of our
requirements right
um so what did we come up with right so
for training
what we did some initial uh
experimentation and we made a decision
to build a model that wasn't task
specific uh and what I mean by that is
our vision was essentially to build a
knowledge graph
which we called the product
understanding engine right uh and the
idea behind this was that similar tasks
need not be learned uh from scratch
right and learning from one task can
help in learning the other right and we
touched upon it briefly in one of our
previous slides
why should learning let's say color of a
product start from scratch when I
already know it's a t-shirt like if I'm
if I'm understanding that a product is a
t-shirt maybe I also kind of understand
what color it is or maybe there's some
commonality in those two tasks and so
can I not start from scratch every time
can I build something that's common
across those layers and then kind of
piggyback on top of that uh so first of
all we started by Framing this as a
multitask multi-class classification
problem
um and the again like I said the idea
was to have this the central layer of
different uh
Central network of layers and then we
can kind of for each task make the
required connections between these
layers to tackle specific tasks right
and then specifically for product
categorization what we did is each level
of the taxonomy is treated as a separate
learning task right so remember that dog
bed dog bed is a level four category
level one category I think is animals
and pet supplies right so predicting
that that product is animals and pet
supplies and level one is a different
task than predicting that it's dog bed
in level four right so we have different
tasks for different levels of the
taxonomy
uh and each task is a multi-class
classification problem right so at level
and the key thing to remember here is
not all levels are equal right the
number of classes at each level is very
different level one for example I
believe has 21 different categories
I think level three or four probably
have 1500 or so right so different
levels are have different number of
categories
um
and then like I said we didn't want to
reinvent the wheel especially because we
were using unstructured data
specifically text and images so we kind
of said there's been a lot of
advancements made in those fields and so
we kind of try to piggyback on top of
pre-trained models uh specifically for
text we use the multilingual bird uh
model and for images we use mobile net
V2
um
so that's kind of where we uh
decided from an architectural
perspective right so we said we're going
to treat this as a multitask
classification problem uh and we're
going to use pre-trained models to kind
of kick start our training
um so this is kind of a rough schematic
of the model architecture itself you're
only seeing it up to level two but like
I said the taxonomy goes all the way
through 11 7 and this graph will
continue all the way to level seven
um and without getting into various
specifics what we do is we feed the text
in the image
for the Ford product or into their
corresponding embedding layers right so
bird and mobile Legends too and what we
then do is we take those embeddings and
feed it into a multi-layer perceptron uh
model that kind of predicts the
the first task right so the first task
in this case is the level one output so
for our dog bed it's going to predict or
hopefully predict uh animals and pet
supplies right what I then do is I take
the output of that layer
concatenated back with my original
inputs and then go through another
multi-layer perceptron to predict level
two and onwards and onwards and onwards
until I hit Level 7 or a terminal load
uh so
like I mentioned earlier
um
there are different levels in the
taxonomy the one thing to keep in mind
here is during this stage the model is
completely taxonomy unaware right as in
Nothing Stops the model from predicting
let's say animals and pet supplies at
level one and then going and predicting
drill bit at level two right uh we'll
come back to that during inference stage
we do something to kind of prevent it
right but at this stage yes we feed in
the top layer to the the top level
prediction to the bottom to kind of try
to influence it what it doesn't
guarantee the parent-child relationship
in the taxonomy is respected we
influence it but there's no guarantees
the embedding layer also train yes
yes
um the raw text is that usually the
product descriptions or names yeah
there's a few different uh fields or
title description tags there's a bunch
of fields that come from our admin page
but yeah essentially descript mostly
titled in description
this is a training
it's simultaneously done for everyday
like it's essentially treated like this
whole thing is treated as a single model
and we train it together so during the
back propagation stage like all like
each each level output is going to have
one loss function associated with it but
again the combined loss is then
aggregated and the gradients are
calculated that way
so so we do training right uh and now
what do we do for predictions right
um
so one of the things we knew is we would
always start with the raw text or the
image right or if it's the first time
they're seeing that product we would
start with the raw text of the image
so
again remember we spoke about the scale
right we we spoke about how many
billions of products and billions of
images we've had and how many millions
of products we are creating every day so
cost was a consideration for us right
like it would be very
easy and lazy of us to kind of say every
time I need every time I need a
prediction just start from scratch take
the raw text In The Raw image and make a
prediction I could do that but it's very
expensive right
um so one of the things we wanted to do
is cache the embeddings if possible so
that the most expensive step in in that
architecture is the embeddings right uh
and so if possible we wanted to try to
see if we can cache the embeddings right
uh and so what we did is we essentially
once the training is complete we kind of
took that big bottle and then split it
into smaller chunks right so we saved
the embedding layers as their own
Standalone models right and we said hey
every time you get a raw text In The Raw
image just pass them through the
embedding layers and save cache the
embeddings right uh and so once you have
those embeddings then you send it to the
the chunk of your model which that's for
the sake of Simplicity call embedding to
probability right so this is the
multi-layer perceptron layers that you
saw
after the embedding layers right so
these will essentially remember we have
multiple tasks so you'll have the
outputs from all of those tasks coming
out specifically for product
categorization we had seven levels so
seven tasks so it will output seven
different vectors or varying lengths
based on how many classes we have per
task and so that's all of the logit
scores for each category in each level
uh and once we have that then we kind of
go saying okay I have all of these
different logic scores for all of these
categories how do I select the
prediction and this is where we kind of
come back remember I said we were
taxonomy unaware during training this is
where we kind of enforce the category
right to enforce the taxonomy so what we
do is we go in and say hey I know you
predicted animals and pet supplies in
level one so regardless of what the
logit scores at level 2 are the
prediction from level two can only be a
child for the from the level one
prediction right and on and on and on
right so we just walk down the taxonomy
to make sure we now have a prediction
that respects the taxonomy itself right
uh and so we have all of these different
Standalone models each of them is their
own thing right
and I can then deploy it as I need to
right so if I let's say I want to do
this in real time then I kind of package
up the whole thing and deploy it as a
single model object and so that way give
me the raw image in the Raw text and
I'll give you the prediction or maybe
you've seen that image before and so now
I want to kind of use only the second
half of that model object so I take the
embeddings from my cache and then send
it to the the rest of the model so now
I'm able to do all of that and this
actually results in quite a bit of
savings both from a compute as well as a
cost perspective
um and so these are essentially the fun
fun foundational fundamental pieces that
we have are
in um in the model and we can kind of
like I said we can start and stop along
any path in that flow
um so we did all of this we built the
model we've deployed it now it's running
how do we measure performance and impact
right uh
obviously we have a bunch of ml metrics
that we kind of track and these are
standard across the fact that it's
hierarchical introduces a little bit of
more complexity but it's nothing that we
cannot solve but more importantly we
didn't want to just focus on ML metrics
we wanted to kind of see was this being
used by our Merchants did they actually
find Value out of it right and as you
can see in a bit we have many internal
applications that use these categories
that we predict but we also wanted to
put all of these predictions in front of
our merchants and see if they find Value
out of it so what we did is essentially
what you're seeing here is the admin
page right if you were to
create a Shopify store and then you want
to create a product this is the page
that you will see so in this case I'm
creating that creating the document
product and you see in the bottom right
over there you see dog beds pop up
that's our prediction right in real time
we've popped the prediction up and our
Merchants now have the option of either
accepting our prediction they can choose
to correct us right so they can go down
there and then they can say hey this
isn't a dog bed it's something else in
which case we immediately use that as
future training data to make our model
better or they can kind of ignore it and
not do anything about it which is
yeah it's the worst possible outcome but
it's a possibility that
and so we kind of measure engagement
here right and so the goal is to kind of
incentivize our Merchants to kind of
engage with that field and they have
plenty of uses for this taxation for
example like if you kind of
um if you adopt that prediction and if
you kind of fill that for us then we can
automatically do taxation for you right
because especially in the United States
what you sell influences how much you
should be taxing that product and it
varies across state lines it's a very
complicated problem so we can do a bunch
of uh workflow improvements for our
Merchants if they kind of adopt that
field uh so we let's so we've now
reached that end of that first stage of
our journey right we've seen how we use
machine learning to do automatic product
categorization and we found some
Merchant use case out of it
um so we now have a Fairly reliable and
scalable way of inferring what kind of
products our Merchants are selling Where
Do We Go From Here Right right are
we kind of looked around to see if there
are any derivative use cases that we
could come up with and we actually found
one that was staring at us in the face
right right and this is the story and
the next step of our journey today is
going to be the story of Shopify
audiences right uh so
again let's go back right so we've
created our product
or fancy machine learning model has now
helped us categorize that we're selling
a dog bit
what's my next step right uh well I have
to find somebody to sell it to right
like somebody now has to pay me money to
send that product over to them right uh
one of the if not the hardest problems
for a merchant when they're trying to
sell their product online is acquiring
new customers uh
so how do they find customers who are
interested to buy that dog bed right or
typically you would do this through some
sort of online advertising platform
right you would go to one of our one of
the common advertising platforms you
would run a campaign and then hopefully
you're able to drive traffic to your to
your website uh problem is most of you
are aware there's a lot of John and
changes happening in the online
advertising space or and we've seen the
starting to affect Shopify emergence
right uh so we kind of looked at it and
we said hey can we do anything that
makes customer acquisition easier for
Shopify merchants
and
this is where Shopify audience's
concerned
um
so what is Shopify audiences well it's a
new way for our Merchants to find High
intent buyers right
um this allows them to be more efficient
in how they spend their money for online
advertising
um
so basically the premise of all of this
is that the collective power of many
Shopify Merchants is individually better
for each one of them to get if they work
together than if they are siled away
right uh but having said that like I
must point out that uh this is also a
voluntary service like it's a so
Merchants have to opt in uh to Shopify
audiences we definitely do not use any
data from Merchants who haven't signed
up to be part of Shopify audience uh and
the reason Shopify audiences works is
because top of my Merchants typically
represent a very niche market and buyers
who purchase from Shopify Merchants
typically are some of the most high
intent customers that you will find uh
on the internet right uh and so this is
where we want to use machine learning
again uh to build on top of product
categorization
to help solve a very critical need that
our Merchants have
um
without getting too much into the detail
on how the specific machine learning
model Works um I'm going to talk to you
about a high level of what how audiences
the product works
so again I said Collective right so
we've now created that dog bed and we're
now like hey I want to run and campaign
that
hopefully gets me
customers who are ready to pay money and
buy my dog bed from me right uh but how
do I do that well I'm gonna go join this
Collective of Shopify merchants and
we've agreed to band together uh with
other Merchants right um
and this is where the machine learning
comes in right so what we do is
essentially we look across all of the
buyers from across those different
merchants in the collective and we kind
of go and look at all of their past
purchase data right uh and Shopify knows
that right because we are powering all
of the checkout or in all of those
Merchant pages right so I know that hey
from Merchant like customer a purchased
a screwdriver from Merchant B and
customer number two purchased dog food
from Merchant C right so I can now go
and say hey that second customer is
probably more likely to buy your dog bed
than the person who bought the
screwdriver right uh so we're
essentially looking at
basically likelihood of purchase of that
particular category based on previous
category purchases uh and so by doing
that we're able to come up with
an audience set right so I take my big
buyer pool I look at all of their
purchase history I then come up with an
audience set and now I know that these
audiences are highly likely to be
interested in purchasing that dog bed
and then I send it over to the ad
platform right so I basically say here
here's all of the audience that you
should be targeting
obviously there's a bunch of privacy
concerns there so we never ever
send identify like even the merchants
are unaware of who those customers are
Shopify directly sends that audience set
to the advertising platform and so this
is actually all like we rolled it out
earlier this year and it's proven to
have increased the efficiency of the ad
spend quite a bit uh and so that was
shot for audiences right that's the
story of how we used we took product
categorization we found a derivative use
case we built a machine learning model
on top of that and it's actually solving
a very critical uh Merchant problem
so so we did that now we're okay we
we've built these two different
no I do not have
right so we've built these two different
uh
models that are kind of related to each
other and we've solved very pertinent uh
uh Merchant problems how do we take it
one step further right uh the next
obvious step was we went back to product
categorization the next obvious step was
was attribute extraction right remember
that slide where we said hey what color
is it what shape is it what size is it
now we want to tackle that problem right
we're not just I'm not content with just
predicting hey this is a dog bed I want
to predict what color it is what size
what shape what material onwards right
uh and as we saw earlier right we use
text and images for our products for
attribute extraction we kind of started
only with images right because we felt
that that was enough right uh and what
we quickly realized is that attributes
are
localized product categories right and
what I mean by that is if I say hey uh
what are the attributes for a t-shirt
right you're probably going to tell me
um neck length or next neck cut sleeve
length color pattern blah blah right
whereas if I tell you hey uh what are
the attributes for a screwdriver it's
very different now right like the kind
of attributes you would have for a
screwdriver are very different so we
quickly realized that product has
product categories was kind of the
anchor before we could get into
attributes right each product category
would have its own set of attributes and
so right there we kind of understood
that we needed uh we needed someone else
right like
I am like as a data scientist I don't
know what all attributes need to be for
every category remember there are 5 500
different categories there's just no
possible way that I'm going to be able
to go in and say hey here are all of the
attributes for each of those categories
so what we essentially did is we relied
on people we call domain experts now for
each domain like let's say fashion for
example we have domain experts
essentially taxonomists who will come in
and tell me hey for t-shirts these are
these are the attributes you have for
parents these are the attributes you
have for hats blah blah blah so once you
have that what they then do is they
create this attribute taxonomy and then
they send it over to a bunch of manual
annotators who are trained right so we
have these annotators go through a
training process who will then create a
small but high quality label data set
for us which is then sent over back to
us and then we pick it up from there and
we train animal models we have an
automated ml training model pipeline
which will like all all our domain
experts have to do is Define a taxonomy
and give us the data
um for the taxonomy and we'll
automatically pick it up and train a
bunch of models and pick the best one
um so right now we're only doing it for
the fashion domain right so within like
you can see right there right so for the
top I'm able to say color type based
blah blah blah and for the band there
are different attributes
um
so this was essentially the product of
attributes right and the commonality
between product like I already spoke to
you about how from a taxonomy
perspective it ties back to the
categories right but even from an
infrastructure perspective it tied back
or to product categorization right
because
for product categorization one of the
things we had to do was build an image
download pipeline right uh I already
spoke to you about how many images we
have like we have tens of billions of
villages right and
moving that kind of images for training
and prediction was non-trivial right and
so we had to build an image download
Pipeline and so we kind of reused a lot
of that for attributes and on top of
that I told you that we were caching a
lot of our embeddings those were also
very useful for attribute extraction uh
again do we need it no is it is it
better to have yes because it results in
a lot of cost savings uh so
a lot of similarity in fact product
categorization and attribute extraction
are essentially now seen as a single
product right or they're built one on
top of the other in fact when a new
product comes in the first thing that
goes is product categorization it'll
predict saying hey this is a dog bit
once that is there then we have it will
automatically say okay this is a dog bed
I need attributes X Y and Z so go run
models X Y and Z right so it's
automatically so we have this knowledge
we have this inference graph of
different models that will kind of based
on the prediction from the previous
model it will decide which model to run
next and then it'll kind of go through
the system until we get all of the
attributes that we need
so those were the three things right so
these are all
these are the three things I wanted to
talk to you about of the different uh
Merchant stories that we uh we're trying
to solve
and now I want to take a step back right
because all of these sound like great
ideas right but how did we actually go
from an idea that a data scientist or an
ml engineer had to something that was
running in production right uh and
that's why I want to kind of finish a
story today the easiest way is to give
you a high level overview of the data
infrastructure
all of shopify's uh infrastructure is
built on top of the Google Cloud
platform
we we've had a very mature data platform
that's been tried and tested over many
many years right uh typically our data
scientists process data using either
spark SQL or stream liquids or Flink or
streaming and so that vertical tower
that you see the data processing tools
that's been existing for a long time now
for
but what we quickly realized is
specifically for production ml use cases
this wasn't enough right uh it it was
needed but it wasn't enough right we
needed some additional capability for ML
and so that's where our new ml platform
comes in right uh and this is like I
want you to meet Merlin we actually have
a blog post so if you go to our Shopify
Tech blog there's a lot more detail
about our machine learning platform but
at a high level
um it's built on top of our production
kubernetes system
um and then on top of that we use this
open source Library called Ray
um to build dedicated environments for
each project or each data scientist
which we call a workspace right and
workspace is essentially
the ability for a data scientist to
control both the hardware as well as the
software that their code is running on
right so I can go in there and say hey
give me I don't know ncpus X gpus these
kinds of gpus this much memory
and then I'll say I need these kind of
libraries installed on it uh and then I
can say I need horizontal scaling Auto
scaling all of that right
and the platform abstracts all of that
away so I give them a configuration file
they take that and they create these
workspaces for me and one of the biggest
advantages that we found by doing this
is that as a data scientist for me I'm
pretty much doing my Dev and stay like
my Dev and staging environments look the
same as what it would look in production
right it's the same Hardware it's the
same software it even has access to the
same production data read-only of course
right
but there's no difference now right
there's no difference between production
staging and Dev it's literally the same
thing and that's amazing right and then
on top of that we have Jupiter access in
each of our workspaces and Ray allows us
the ability to do distributed uh
distributed computing so I can do
distributed training on tensorflow Pi
torch XT boost whatever it is whichever
framework you want to use for your
modeling you can do that on Ray right
um
and all of this has made it extremely
easy for us to move from
a Dev staging experimentation and then
finally into production right uh and so
we did all that and then on top of that
we have like additional tools like uh
like we have a model registry feature
store uh we have online inference
service all of that built in uh in our
ml platform and so those kind of like
it's super easy for me to now spin up
the workspace and then kind of
experiment on top
uh and so if we come now to the end of
our journey right uh I did want to
emphasize that all of these successes
that we've had has been the result of
multiple teams kind of interacting with
each other uh I'm standing here today or
talking about these wheels wins on the
shoulder of some of the best colleagues
that I could ever uh hope to work with
and uh we've had many many learnings
along this way like all of all of the
things that I spoke to you about this
has been a couple of years of learning
and iteration for us uh and um we hope
to pick up the pace right like we're
hoping to iterate much faster uh the
platform's changing we are learning how
to kind of improve the way we do things
and uh we're hoping we're able to
deliver a lot more success for our
Merchants uh and with that uh I come to
the end of my presentation and uh if I
have the time I can answer a few
questions
[Applause]
thanks a lot for that insightful session
yeah um
we are running uh slightly over time but
I think we can still spend a couple of
minutes uh for the Q a session
um
is there someone uh with questions
so
um so I was wondering like when you
spoke with the audience set
um and you said that you're basically
looking at people who have already said
for example what a dog bed and so you
kind of anticipate that they're gonna
buy a chicken but also like did you
consider like user similarities looking
at approaches about the users this
person is probably going to buy a dog
too was that one of the things
I mean yeah that's mostly what we do
right so we look at all of our previous
users right we look at all their
purchases
we basically figure out like let's say
like again very nice example right let's
say we found that people who bought
dog food regularly for the last six
months are more likely to buy a dog bed
then if I find somebody who's had
regular purchases of dog food yes I'm
gonna say hey these this person looks
similar to those other people and so
yeah and then on top of that once we
send it over once we send over that
audience set to the online advertising
platforms they have similarity like
likelihood or similar so you can send I
can send them a list of I don't know 20
000 people and they can find similar
people to that 20 000 people as well
right so it happens at multiple stages
let's take your um I mean
okay
thank you so much uh it was amazing
my question you said the ad platform
which is it the secret which platform
are you know right now we uh I think we
support integration to Facebook
um I think we're going to launch uh
Google ads as well soon or who is paying
for that the customer or you
paying for 100 000.
customer
like they're already running ads like
our customers are already running ads on
Facebook
with Facebook's own targeting uh system
so this is just a different way for them
to manage their Facebook campaigns
they're already running ads on Facebook
this is just a run it with our targeting
so that you can see better return on
investment for your
right can you include that in the
membership fee for a certain section I
think right now audiences is only
launched to a certain subscription tier
in the US only but we plan to roll it
out to other locations and other
services